c'est au palais de la source que s'est
déroulé ce lundi 14 décembre la remise
des prix du concours
ok chefs organisé par le conseil
départemental depuis plusieurs années la
collectivité s'est inscrite dans une
démarche volontariste de valorisation
des produits pays
cette deuxième édition du concours ok
chef est une action menée à l'intention
des collèges et des primaires ce
concours ok chef est l'occasion pour le
département au d'ouvrir les restaurants
scolaires de nos collèges mais également
des écoles primaires aux produits péi de
la réunion c'est une façon pour nous de
ce lait sensibiliser à la production
locale et encourager également à la
découverte de nos produits souvent
anciens qu'on ne retrouve plus forcément
dans les supermarchés mais là on a
l'occasion effectivement d'aussi donner
l'envié aux jeunes de découvrir un
métier et de découvrir ce métier avec
les produits de la réunion les produits
authentiques
c'est notre façon à nous de valoriser la
production réunionnaise si le collège
joseph-hubert de saint-joseph qui a
remporté le premier prix cette année
grâce à leur menu intitulé mélange des
saveurs du sud sauvage
l'équipe vainqueur composé d'un chef de
cuisine et de deux élèves s'est vu
remettre un trophée ainsi que de
nombreux cadeaux
mais terminer premier on est très
content qu'on ait gagné on est terminée
en troisième on s'attendait pas du tout
à un premier aujourd'hui bon et ça fait
chaud au coeur
une amie qui a beaucoup à voir quelque
chose là on a réussi je remercie le
souvent tout mon équipe
les défis surtout ce qui est important
c'est que les élèves mangent bien mon
métier ces données nous en france qui
vit bien assez cru comme disait monsieur
patate barreaux et une hache à quelque
chose je sais pas remis dans la set
avant que les denrées arrivent dans
l'assiette il ya beaucoup de travail en
amont est vrai que travaille beaucoup
trop cher ce que fait tous les jours
pour le proviseur du collège joseph
hubert l'objectif de ce concours est de
promouvoir la production locale
valoriser le savoir faire d'une équipe
mais aussi sensibiliser et impliquer les
élèves à la conception d'un menu
équilibré
c'est un concours important parce que
non seulement ça prend aux jeunes
véritablement comprendre le but et en
plus le bout pays
et la cerise sur le gâteau eux mêmes à
eux de faire cette cuisine c'est à eux
de mélanger ses saveurs et c'est
important de retrouver ainsi ses racines
culinaire les élèves participent même si
un hâle que deux qui font la cuisine les
autres véritablement que gut et ils
savent que ce concours est là et ils
sont attentifs dans ce rôle de jury et
ea aussi ça leur apprend à véritablement
à mieux qu'au mieux connaître le goût
pays le second prix a été remis au
collège bourbon pour son menu métissage
pays
le troisième prix a été décerné au
collège titan avec un menu intitulé
harmony de saveurs pays